Our Centres – Ō Tātou Pūtahi
With the majority of post-earthquake restoration
work now complete in the Kaiapoi and Rangiora
Town Centres, we now turn our minds towards
the long-term future of all our centres.
Retailing trends are evolving, online shopping
is prevalent and big box stores are increasingly popular.
It’s vital our town centres are ‘lifestyle’
centres with complementary activities and
community, recreational and entertainment facilities
all creating a place where people like to spend time.
Our District - Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz